raging wildfires in texas have now
turned deadly a sheriff's deputy was
killed trying to save others officials
are sifting through the destruction as
crews tried to gain the upper hand
during a break in the weather jennifer
johnson reports
it's a race against time for texas
firefighters as gusty winds are
predicted to return sunday the
wind-fueled wildfires have already
scorched hundreds of kilometers
destroying almost the entire town of
ranger i've been fire chief here 40
years and
and when you have something like this it
hurts it hurts the whole community the
largest wildfire is burning in eastland
county surrounded by thick brush and
grassy areas hundreds of homes there
have been evacuated one sheriff's deputy
sergeant barbara finley was going door
to door telling people to get out but
lost her life after returning to check
on an elderly resident she was out
serving trying to evacuate people and
just
tragedy struck
and but she's going to be missed so much
finley leaves behind a husband and three
children the governor of texas paid his
respects to the first responder later
declaring 11 counties a disaster already
we know that there have been at least
50 homes that have been lost
probably as we are able to better
surveil
damages here in the coming days we will
find more than that the smoke is so
heavy air quality warnings have been
issued in houston five hours away
several months of dry windy weather have
fueled deadly fires in kansas oklahoma
nebraska and now texas we are not out of
danger
yet for our high hazard fire risk so we
just ask that the community take sincere
caution in your outdoor activities low
visibility from heavy smoke is hampering
firefighters on the ground and in the
air but there is one sign of hope
showers are in the forecast next week
jennifer johnson global news washington